better than the white was just such an
amazing thing to be involved with him
and he kind of can feel that it's gonna
be a dynamic project anyway sugar is the
leading lady in the prostitutes sugar
and I want you to just capture her kind
of innocence to begin with so the
Starling wasn't she was young you know a
young young girl quite in the sort of in
the higher Victorian fashion but I row
very much her own stubborn person in the
book she's she's very well-read she's
very clever and that's also a
fascination while she keeps her close
it's not only about the sex but also
she's very bright and very knowledgeable
so that had to kind of come across so I
also styled sugar that she was the only
one that had red hair I didn't want
anybody else with the red it had to be
just her for Ramla to stand out so my
approach was to find the right red color
that's a journey yeah but you know to
find the redness of the hair and what it
would look like and again the references
into in the book was that her hair when
he touched it was millions of colors
Reds he could see purples Gold's bronze
yellows in her one head of hair so I
tried to kind of achieve that with wefts
and different things in with the mix of
the actual wigs that we got got some
very severe Thank You Christopher no
Genting toe
Elizabeth dead well into a better place
always said she would didn't she her
first look was worried innocent and then
when she mr. Rackham decided to buy her
she then becomes his mistress and she
has to mingle with the upper-class
people so she I then gave her the
Victorian styling that's all she did all
day was preen and wait for him because
now he owned her basically so she wasn't
gonna be seeing any other clients so
basically she was just doing herself up
and meeting him in cafes and different
places this is her sort of first taste
of being a bit more of a decadent girl
you know with the ringlets and the hair
over to the side and head back and then
the breaking down of the style you know
as she's having sex you know things get
broken down when mr. Rackham comes back
in to meet her she's in a dressing gown
there she's waiting for him and you know
the stars all the tailor down into the
center
the next look when she has a chance to
be the governess she cuts her hair off
to become to play the part of the little
girl's nanny basically so I changed her
with a fringe and did a various
governess style and that kind of kept
the look really from in to at 3:00 in -
at 4:00 but then obviously she has she's
carrying Williams child so I break the
style down because she's getting sicker
and I appearance she starts to get weary
and you know the whole journey of her is
not really about her look anymore
it's breaking it down a little bit to
look more disheveled you know and she
wants to you know help get missing men
Agnes Rackham out of helps her run away
and helps the kid xscape she ends up
kidnapping the child so it's not you
know I kind of carried on with the
styling and if it makes me sense just it
kept that one look when she was the
governess here people go to sleep as
soon as the gym takes effect
you've allowed yourself to be led astray
and there's no hope of finding your way
back so we're doing a full lace wig on
high definition isn't really a hard
thing to pull off and especially with
the mid Victorian styles it's all off
the face more or less I also gave sugar
a little bit of a unique styling because
most of the styles in Victorian times
were middle partings and back off the
face white actually took the liberty of
taking it more over to the side which
was quite a unique feel which is not you
don't you look at many references over
to the side which that gave it again her
own quirkiness why Mr Hunt what a
pleasure mr. hunt has a proposition you
sugar so I understand if I may what none
of us understands is outside of your
arrangement with the house itself what
will you pay sugar oh no whatever makes
her happy Martin Wyndham was in the most
amazing director to work with a very
approachable and very amicable and we
gelled instantly on our taste and our
designs he gave me some reference and
that was the otto dix
which is like really kind of kind of
weird that when we went to Canada to
film the second part of the of they
because it was shot in two places one in
England then we went to Canada
later with a new team and the Otto Dix
exhibition was there which is really
kind of crazy and a lot of otto dix
pictures are very quite grotesque and he
wanted to do to bring that into the
victorian life I am mrs. castaway some
of the prostitutes styling of all that
was very sort of meant to be kind of
very Otto Dix and in in the brothel that
you see with all the fat people and it
wasn't meant to be very grossed and
smeared lips and beauty spots but he was
absolutely wonderful to collaborate with
and then obviously the actors have
always got their
kind of fear of the character so I
fitted everybody and yeah I did their
own quirk to each design I wanted to get
that across with everybody really there
were their unique personalities so how
they how they were who they were playing
in them in the parts you know I believe
that you get a project that you'd kind
of kind of you know you go out for jobs
that you want to do obviously so I'd
like to try and do my best with whatever
I'm given and bring the best I can to
whatever that project is and I have that
attitude even if I'm doing a freebie
low-budget or making big-budget movies
but I think it's all it's not about the
money it's about what you do with it so
I think that's I think you know I'm used
to I suppose making the lower budgets
look good I guess but I it's rubbish if
it's not about the money it's what you
can do with it and I think that's the
difference I think this yes I do that's
what I've always done you know I kind of
I'm not had that luxury of I mean big
bucks to to play around with so I've had
to use my imaginations and resources and
bring something bringing you and look to
a project